SCP-096 Vs SCP-835. The terrifying,
unstoppable killer known as the Shy Guy,
against a truly sickening abomination.
Which would win? Let’s find out!
835 is a huge, underwater monster made from
human flesh, a kind of nightmarish coral
formation with giant, grasping tentacles. It
drags people inside to add to its own biomass
and releases an infectious pathogen that
transforms humans into terrible, violent beasts.
However, we still think SCP-096 would
have a good chance to survive here.
Not only is it hardy and
relentless, it also isn’t human,
and SCP-835 appears specifically geared to
integrate humans into its body. As a result,
there’s a good chance that 096 would be
immune to the worst of SCP-096’s effects.
And that might be enough for it to
fight back and take home the win.